c'est un village médiéval de sicile
planté au pied du mont san paolino
village ancrée dans les traditions mais
le visage de ce terrain a beaucoup
changé au cours des dernières années les
retraités italiens y croise de plus en
plus de migrants venus d'afrique et du
moyen orient
mais lorsque nous avons lancé une
initiative du maire de ce terreau a émis
par les multiples naufrage en mer
méditerranée
la préfecture nous a appelés pour nous
demander si nous avions de la place dans
notre cimetière pour enterrer les morts
de lampedusa dit il je leur ai répondu
qu'on avait pas de place pour les morts
mais qu'on pouvait accueillir les
vivants
de mon côté en bourse peut pas rêver
depuis une cinquantaine de migrants se
sont installés dans les nombreuses
maisons vides du village comme vous
c'est nous d'hazard et sa femme sumatra
fraîchement arrivé du pakistan avec leur
fils de 7 mois mort hamad
il rêve maintenant de s'installer pour
de bon en caux et frost jurés ce pays
s'ils désirent apprendre la langue et
trouver du travail de nouveaux lots
comme beaucoup de villages en sicile
sutera est frappé de plein fouet par
l'exode rural la population ici est
passé en quelques dizaines d'années à
peine de plus de cinq mille personnes à
peine 1500 aujourd'hui dans ces
circonstances le maire de souterrains
voile immigrants comme une chance pour
le village notre école était menacée de
fermeture des peuplements dit il mais
grâce à l'arrivée de ces demandeurs
d'asile on a pu la garder ouverte pour
ses maladresses ses enseignants on en
profite et pour sensibiliser tous les
élèves aux difficultés qu'ont vécu leurs
nouveaux petits camarades
ils ont consacré des cours aussi à la
question des droits de l'homme le maire
est ravi de l'expérience enfants
s'intègrent parfaitement et l'énergie
qu'ils nous transmettent nous encourage
dit il on se dit qu'on a fait quelque
chose de bien
margaret au congo en tout cas le
constate ces enfants sont bien ici
cette mère célibataire n'a pas eu la vie
facile depuis son départ du nigeria mais
elle se sent aujourd'hui chez elle à
souterrain j'adore cet endroit c'est
petit
les gens sont gentils et accueillants
elle rêve maintenant d'ouvrir salon
coiffure et espère une vie meilleure
pour ses enfants
le responsable du programme en tout cas
est très optimiste sur l'intégration des
corps lui la proximité des migrants
comme les autres habitent ce village
facilite leur intégration sans démesure
vielle à roue est convaincu que le
bénéfice est mutuel d'ailleurs pas top
des communautés ils font partie de la
communauté dit il
et l'endroit a beaucoup changé avec la
ruine des sports pierre
une chose est certaine si margaret a
aujourd'hui adopté avec bonheur la
cuisine et la culture de l'italie elle a
aussi apporté avec elle à sousceyrac les
rythmes du nigeria